there were soldiers and armored vehicles
on the streets another tense night in
myanmar
but despite the security patrols and an
internet blackout
protesters gathered for a tenth straight
day
one group of the civil disobedience
movement cdm for short
stood in front of the central bank in
yangon and continued with their calls
for the military government to step down
and the country's democratically elected
leaders
to be released we are protesting
peacefully without weapons and with no
intention of violence
to call for cdm and fight for the
freedom of government staff
this says the military junta issued a
statement on its facebook page
outlining the possible punishments for
protesters
saying any act spoken or written that
expresses or
incites hatred of the government could
lead to 20 years in prison
people gathered outside a court in the
capital naperdor hoping that deposed
civilian leader onsong tsuchi
would be released on monday those hopes
soon dashed
according to the remand which was set
today is the last day of the remand
period
but from the discussions with the
district justice the remain period is
now until the 17th
not today tsuchi was one of the first to
be detained in the early hours of the
coup
two weeks ago she's been charged with
illegally importing six walkie-talkie
radios
according to a monitoring group more
than 400 people have now been detained
since the february first coup
there's a vast range of people within
that group and that's of real concern
for 23 year old fortune teller charlotte
a fellow yangon fortune teller was
arrested a few days ago
after a video of him praying for the
military to fail went viral
since they're dictators they can make up
whatever laws they like to oppress us
we astrologers are like birds in their
hands if they squeeze we are dead
if they let us fly we are free this is
the nature of dictatorship
and it's not just happening to us it's
everyone
and that's probably why protesters are
coming out in strength the ruling
national league for democracy nld party
won by a landslide in last november's
election and was
extremely popular most see this move by
the military as a nullification of their
vote
and their voice scott heidler al jazeera
so let's go live to david capalan who's
following developments from hong kong
in divya so we've heard about soldiers
shooting
at the protest what more do we know
that's right in the city of mandalay
which is the second largest city of
in myanmar we've heard that security
forces and police were shooting to
disperse protesters there
now it's unclear whether they were using
a rubber bullet or
live fire now in that city the protest
movement has been
quite strong as it has been in the
largest city yangon which is also the
commercial hub
and for the first time there there have
been tanks and armored vehicles on the
streets
and as scott said in his report people
still remain defiant
video of people shouting at the military
to leave
and cars honking their disappear
disapproval have been circulating now
despite their that their defiance there
is still a lot of concern though that
the situation could escalate given that
those
uh soldiers in those tanks and then
those that have been seen on the streets
are combat soldiers with a reputation
for
brutality so there is worry that
there still could be bloodshed and the
situation
could deteriorate but so far the
protesters are holding strong
and coming out in their numbers and all
as all that is going on
angstan tsuchi's hearing has been pushed
forward to wednesday
do we know what might happen then
very hard to tell the goalposts have
been moving
consistently uh the aung tang tsuchi's
lawyers say
the judge says it's on wednesday but
whether she will actually appear
in court or whether the court
proceedings will be further delayed it's
unclear
now presumably the military junta is
very concerned about having
aung suchi appear in any kind of public
forum as she's seen as the symbol
of this democratic movement and having
her out in public could just galvanize
the protest
movement now given that the military
government
has changed the laws over the weekend
and these laws once again will
affect both angsangsu's trial and also
the way
things operate on the ground and one of
those laws
is of particular concern to the
protesters especially as we're coming up
to
curfew now where many of the protesters
will be heading home in about half an
hour but also along with the cover of
darkness comes the arrests and
one of those laws basically gives the
security forces
the ability to arrest people without any
court orders
and that's what's been happening these
security forces and police have been
going into people's homes
searching them making random arrests
without any charges and so far four
hundred people
have been arrested they include allies
of an song tsuchi politicians human
rights activists protesters
student leaders journalists and the list
goes on so
as darkness falls now what many of these
protesters will be worrying about
is their personal safety and whether
they will be next
all right vivian thanks for that david
palin following events there in myanmar
from hong kong
let's hear now from nikki diamond who's
a human rights specialist at fortify
rights in yangon
and he says there's no end in sight for
the protest movement
today we called a nationwide cdn
civil disobedient movement uh now
a lot of protest in front of the
syndrome central ban
so the situation last night very intense
we have
internet blackout 1am to 9am
and also during that time military start
arresting people
around around the country we don't know
how many people are arrested but the
the situation is very intense during the
election we have a different kind of
group
but right because of this military crew
all people in the countries are united
against the military
even who dislike the nld right now they
are marching on the street
who who are noble and also they are
mushy on the street again the
this military military coup so that
happened
and also that also we are now united
against the
uh military